There are two-toed sloths and three-toed sloths,
but other than their toes -- what's the difference?!
Hello friends, I'm Trace thanks for tuning
in to DNews!
As you're likely aware, it's SLOTH WEEK!
Obviously, we're all aware sloths are cute,
slow-moving, and extremely photogenic -- but
let's drill down a little further into these
South American darlings.
Why do some sloths have two toes and some
have three?
Because evolution.
First, both two-toed and three-toed sloths
have three ACTUAL toes.
Yes, two-toed sloths have three TOES, but
only two FINGERS.
35 to 40 million years ago, the 2-toed and
3-toed sloth were one species, Tara talked
about that in a different video about ancient
sloth ancestors -- go watch if you missed
it -- but at some point they mutated into
these two distinct groups.
The 3-toed megatherium -- or great beast,
which was the size of an elephant and the
2-toed megalonyx -- or great claw.
As they evolved the sloths shrank in size
and spread themselves through North and South
America -- probably to conserve energy, because
leaves aren't THAT nutritious.
Though it could also be because movement attracts
predators.
23-percent of the diet of Harpy Eagles is
made up of two-toed sloths, and only 8.4-percent
by the three-toed ones.
I think you can guess who moves more.
Two-toed sloths may move for several hours
throughout the day, while some species of
the three-toed sloth won't move at all.
In case you ever run into a sloth, the two-toed
guy are larger, faster, nocturnal, and can
rotate their head 90 degrees [[pause]] the
three-toed ones are slower and more docile,
and can rotate their head 270 degrees and
can be either nocturnal or diurnal.
Get all that?
Great.
More importantly for you on the internet.
The three-toed are more often the ones you
see taken as pets, BECAUSE they're cute, they
don't bite and, like I said, they tend to
be more docile.
That doesn't help with their natural existence
however, because people keep TAKING THEM HOME.
There are four species of the three-toed sloth:
The Maned, Pale-Throated, Brown-Throated and
Pygmy.
The three-toed sloths have a blunter muzzle,
and simpler, peg-like teeth.
The cutest of those is definitely the pygmy.
As it's name suggests, it's real tiny.
It separated from the other three species
almost 9,000 years ago and lives solely on
Isla Escudo de Veraguas off the coast of Panama.
Because it only lives in that ONE PLACE, it's
definitely endangered.
The two-toed sloth is ALSO really cute, I
am sure you can see a theme here...
But because it has a more defensive temperament
it will be to defend itself.
There are only TWO species of two-toed sloth:
The Linnaeus's and Hoffman's.
The Linnaeus' sloth has a HUGE land area and
super a strong population because it's got
great camouflage and is solitary, but the
Hoffmans... is a victim of it's own cuteness.
It's population is strong as well, but the
Hoffmans tend to venture onto farmland where
they can be killed.
They're also hunted and captured for the exotic
pet trade, again, because cuteness.
Another big difference between the two, is
the three-toed sloth, like humans, has a sex
ratio at birth of about 1-to-1 female-to-male.
But that two-toed devil has 11-to-1!
Eleven females for every male.
When you spot a two-sloth in the wild, look
for others, because the females form small
groups, and the males are solitary.
In the end, whether it be two or three toes
-- the sloths are fascinating natives to the
Americas with a rich history and pretty complicated
family life.
Which is your favorite, the two or three toed
sloth?
Tell us in the comments below!
And in case you didn't hear before: it's Sloth
Week!
Check out all the awesome sloth videos on
our sister network: Animalist.
You can find more sloths by going to YouTube.com/Animalist
or by going to SlothWeek.com.
We've put links in the description below!
You can also come back to DNews for more awesome
videos everyday!